everyone's here who's
coming
um
gotta start with the emergency
evacuation announcement
i'll read
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please hold both hand rails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery
if anyone is unable to use the stairs
would they please allow others to exit
the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can then be given
assistance
our assembly point will be in the public
car park of the site civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation
defects and collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
thank you
apologies for absence we've had um
councillor draen councillor hazelwood
um
non-members of attending we have
councillor mcpherson councillor melton
the minutes of the meeting held on third
february 2015. is that everyone
okay if i sign those
that is done
thank you
um
to receive declarations of interest
i think
perhaps i should declare an interest i'm
a member of
rochester housing association board
of personal interests
chairman customers
the same
right
now move on to
item five which is some
entitled phone listeners and i'd like to
thank them
emma pegan for coming from rockford
housing association we did invite some
other people but they haven't
turned up unfortunately
um which is genesis
housing association and also
mungo's who who do work with the
homeless in the area
um
the idea of this is we're just trying to
find information find facts find what we
do
really so
it shouldn't be too hard hopefully i
think we're going to start with
counselor
glenn thank you very much and i have a
series of questions and i i'll go
through them so you can write them down
and then i would like an answer at the
end
of the lot together follow the questions
to are there to
the other lady there who i don't know is
unusual
my question to do with homeless is how
many properties in the housing
associations have temporary
accommodation
that are available for homeless
situations across the area
meaning how many have you got that are
already available at short notice
how much of this temporary accommodation
is based in south end of battlefront
on average what period are people in
temporary accommodation for
does the temporary accommodation supply
have facilities for people to cook how
much does it cost to put somebody into
this accommodation
how much does a district pay towards the
temporary accommodations
thank you councillor you're looking at
back and give an answer to the lord
all right the other thing is how much
does the company if the district have to
pay towards their temporary
accommodation and does it count or does
it come from the people's benefit
we're passing um them a copy of the
equivalent of actually started
somewhere yeah so good writing
okay
what arrangements are made if children
are involved to allow them to continue
to get as attend their normal school
does the person in temporary
accommodation have to pay for their own
heating and lighting and if so is it by
a meter
they're my questions and i know there's
others from elsewhere
can we take them one at a time yeah we
take them on a time it might be easier
i think that was question six through to
13 is that correct no yeah i mean his
question is they have problems with the
questions i think sorry
it would have been quite helpful to have
had these questions prior to the meeting
because we won't have all this
information i thought some of
them
um
some questions would have been revision
tonight from our discussions before the
meeting as well obviously if you can't
answer them
you you can come back but we'll see
where we can go with them
so our three question three
has been provided already for instance
around do you provide any temporary
accommodation
yeah yeah and i think it was
that one weekend i think the question
behind jess was probably been looking
forward as well
i think um yeah from my perspective we
were given questions one two five
beforehand so they're the ones i've
prepared yeah but then but i think well
the questions would intend to give a
flavor of what we would be asking for as
well so so i think the council's uh
question started at number six how many
properties does um do the housing
association have um available for
template accommodation so our rochefort
housing association at the point of
stock transfer when we took over the
stock from the council there was an
agreement that we would supply a certain
number of units for homeless
accommodation and that is eight fixed
units so there's six units at hatfield
house on east street in rochford
obviously the council previously owned
and they're a mix of one and two bedroom
properties and they're all
self-contained and
then the council have availability of up
to six other units that we have so they
can be any size anywhere within the
district so overall it's 14 that are
available what i would say is that
we also make available other properties
if they come up and they're not suitable
for us to let on a permanent basis so to
give you an example we have a unit at
the moment that would have been tied
accommodation for scheme manager we
haven't replaced that position we don't
have residential scheme managers
appointed going forward so that property
is now vacant it's not suitable to let
as a general needs property permanently
or family accommodation permanently
because it's attached to a sheltered
scheme so we've made that unit available
for temporary accommodation so that's
all the flexibility that we have
um
thank you chairman um in addition to
that about this um there may be others
because obviously we've only just
looked at the temporary accommodation
and genesis have got nine um swan has
have got three um necro which provides
single accommodation have got three and
century house got one
how long are they in that temporary
accommodation
are they in there purely for two or
three weeks or in their in there for
months
bearing in mind that you do have a
housing
a a list
for people that are looking for
on the housing register
so
these ones that you say you've got
available either across the top whole
time there are always at least one
property available at any time and right
to answer um i don't have the statistics
available of how long people are in
there but it will be months rather than
weeks um
well i would say that's a figure that
the council will have because it's you
obviously have the statutory duty to
homelessness so i can't give you that
figure off the off the top of my head
it's not something that we would monitor
and so it's really a council
responsibility because you have the
statutory duty and but
is anything available at the moment it
is because um the council aren't using
their full quota of the six flexible
units so um at the moment there would be
an accommodation available um
potentially under that agreement i
suppose what you need to then think is
we don't have properties just sat around
waiting for people so if we were to give
you one of those six
flexible units that obviously would mean
that someone who couldn't permanently be
housed so we would you know it's uh
it's a decision that the council has to
make if they want to nominate someone
temporarily or permanently to a property
chairman we can uh provide that data to
the group um obviously um depending on
the size of the family and their needs
some are in there longer than other
families
the other question i had asked was what
happens about children going to school
and
and the costings of being in the
temporary accommodation
who
is he stood up to the parents do is
there any assistance in taking
children's school if they moved outside
the area for instance
john would you know otherwise we've
passed that back
again we can provide that information uh
i don't think that should be too
difficult um and indeed um
the
uh the costs of uh temporary
accommodation are
reported through the budget but we can
we can provide the information uh some
detailed information on that development
to the committee
is it possible for you to give answers
for that to all of us in writing yes
how much does it cost to put something
in temporary accommodation i understand
there could be things around storage of
furniture and things like that which
they may meet or we may meet temporarily
um some information around that as well
so we're asking about how much did it
cost it would be ancillary costs as well
not just the physical cost of
paying for the accommodation itself but
also actually across around storage of
furniture as well
they have some
i think that's what you meant as well
as well
but i think
i think the other
question council looking for is
um
where else um how much of this temporary
accommodation is based in
south embarrassing said but what we're
referring to is that some people also
put into bed and breakfast accommodation
and is that on a
contract basis is that just an ad hoc
basis or do we have contracts with
the people and whereabouts is that
bnb accommodation base how much is in
the district how much is in
other barons or districts um chairman i
haven't got the exact figure some are in
the russia district some are based
outside but we can give you a full
analysis of that as well and the
costings for each yeah i think in the
past you have as well yeah
is that a yes okay
yeah i think um did you want to leave us
next well i can do if you like yesterday
before let's cross what i was going to
say because obviously we don't know what
you're going to say but
i feel confident you're going to come
back with an answer the first question
is is there a register or record kept of
all persons who applies homelessness
um
regardless of whether you give them
homeless
you know accommodation so they come in
and moved elsewhere so do you keep a
record of all those people
um and two do we these are the questions
the two do we have a well i know some of
it but do we have a rush for a district
council strategy or policy to deal with
homelessness under the homeless persons
act
question three
what did the local localism build i
don't know what does the localism build
change if anything in relationship in
relation to homelessness
yeah
i think you'll find it's number 16 about
this
even though we only have one to five yes
thank you
and also what are the keys stakeholders
of rockford's homelessness prevention
strategy
okay um art psychically um
thank you chairman um yes there are
records kept a river but
um for homelessness um obviously if they
meet the criteria and we've got a duty
of care for those people then we look to
be home
um
we've got a homeless strategy which was
recently revised so that has probably
taken into account localism bill but
i'm sure shauna um correct me if not um
that has been circulated to all members
but i can have that circulated again to
this group
and what was um local israel
um it's localism act
i'm grateful for some advice on the
particular
the particular clause in the localism
act that uh the committee might have in
mind in response
it was a bill when it started
would you like to
um what part of the act do you think um
has impacted on well i don't know
i'm not chairman numbers are aware that
and who are the key stakeholders i
appreciate you got housing
is there anybody else involved in for
example do we have groups going out
homeless persons and if we do what do we
do with them if we buy them
chairman
because because because i've written
down a list so you know in terms of the
people that local authority works with
on homelessness issues we work with
the registered providers obviously we
work with the citizens of vice bureau
family mosaic macro private landlords
extended schools family solutions essex
county council the police
we work with women's aid and refugees
and we work with other local authorities
i mean i don't know if that's a
definitive list but
you know there's a long list of
what we've
people that we work with in relation to
homelessness issues
oh
and
i think
perhaps one of
cancer um
laura's questions was around
do we keep a record of
those of homies i think i'm not i just
want to clarify the answer um
do we keep a list of people who come in
and say that they regard themselves as
homeless or do we only keep an account
of those who come in and say they're
homeless and we agree at homeless
a good question and a good nuance
difference between the two i believe we
keep a record of all people that
approach the council that's part of the
strategy duty
but i can i can advise the committee on
the details of that okay sorry counselor
could i add to that chairman um that
obviously there are people who do not
come to the council at all and do not
declare themselves as homeless and we
actually actively engage and work with
the police to try to identify those
people within our community as well
because i think that was also something
around
castle was asking if we could have a
count of
rough sleepers or which are going in
yourself you start i understand you can
start getting
is some when he's right someone a rough
sleeper or not i don't know um sorry
just briefly come back and your answer
was that people you do know when people
have come in the number of times i've
been in the main office in rockford and
people come in and ask about being
homeless and that and they're nev their
names and addresses are never taken
they're just told
go off and do something and it's it's
not just once it's on a regular basis it
doesn't seem as though there is enough
um
in the outer office the people to these
staff to know um what to do so thank you
councilman may i say chairman if any
member has witnessed that and these are
vulnerable people in our community why
have they not scaled that up
why have i not been made aware of this
before now
that would be my answer to that okay so
something we have said with these
members and now no i've said about it
before not to me no but i have to other
people if you could let me know after
that chairman then i can tell you that
can we arrange that to happen so we can
deal with that because i think it's
really important
um
i've got a question i kind of um it's
not on the list but but it comes from
what
council of goon was just talking about
um could there be any in any instances
where people who um present to us as
being homeless
are moved on
from rochford
to maybe south end or basildon because
we can't help them for any reason
when you say we can't help them
if they meet the criteria
then we have a duty to help them
okay you you've answered the question
judy um
do we you know
does anybody ever ever escape the
the the net
we say we've got a duty
that duty is to identify and assist
is it is it not a talk is it possible at
all that someone could could just slip
through that piece and we say well
actually we can't do anything
we don't have this we don't have that
you know um so maybe if you went to
south end or maybe if you went to
basildon you'd be better off
i'm not making you being accusative i'm
i'm just
thinking
look um we know there's a duty
do we ever can we get it wrong do we get
it often right
i mean i think the the issue the issue
here uh uh
i think is is related to
uh whether or not the council
um takes action to deal with on a
temporary basis someone who presents us
homeless until such time
as it's determined whether that person
is intentionally homeless or whether
through some some other uh um qualifying
arrangement the council has a duty to
how's that that that that person or that
or that family does that does that make
sense which is why
um
some people uh when they present
themselves they will be put into into
into bed and breakfast or then temporary
accommodation until such time as that
assessment is is carried out
does that make sense yes
and i think probably what happened i'll
tell you what i'll tell you why i'm
raising it okay
there's anecdotal evidence popping up
you know which in my hearing if you like
not individuals beating their way to my
door and saying look rockford you know a
thing like that there's a feeling in the
larger towns
that people from our area
are are ending up
their responsibility the responsibility
of south end and basildon rather than
ourselves for some reason and i've just
i just posed that question in that way
not to tease it out but to ask it
politely no i suppose i have to ask it
more directly than i thought i'd have to
yeah that's um thank you counselor sam
uh perfectly acceptable but i can tell
you of one case
that we're almost convinced
southend has got a duty to home this
family
we are still
housing that family rather than be out
on the street and then we are looking
investigating it if south and i found
that they should have been housed in
that family they will be footing the
bill
it sounds like there could be football
here
and that's you know kind of where where
i think i'm hearing that people are
being you know shunted from pillar two
and i think that's what maybe counselor
glenn has maybe heard i don't know the
reasons for it but it seems to be
that sounded like an example of that
um well
do you want to explain the criteria
about whether we have a neighboring
i think my feeling is that
some authorities are
asking specific questions of people who
present themselves as uh as homeless and
they're making
very
rapid judgments about whether or not
they should
intervene
and are
sending those people uh away
and suggesting they go elsewhere i think
that's my my feeling about the situation
and they often end up at rochester
i know i'm hoping this question but i
suppose it is mine yeah um
have we got have we thought of trying to
quantify that in any way in in
because we keep the records
of people whether they qualify or not is
there is there a way we could actually
try and capture you know some of that
that's turning up
in russia that shouldn't
well we should be able to and apart from
that um without um you know
obviously bearing in mind data
protection we could provide a couple of
case studies
um
yeah i'm getting a little bit confused
with some of these questions and what it
exactly is i want to ask
is there a way of
finding the numbers of those that are
homeless through domestic violence
those that rough sleeping
those are sofa surfing
and perhaps evicted
um through non-payment of rent
that's number one
also
with those that are
declared intentionally homeless and that
could be for a number of reasons i know
is there any although they're
intentionally homeless they're still
homeless and they're perhaps still our
residents and they found themselves in
difficult situations or whatever
is there any support given to those
after it's been declared that they are
now intentionally homeless so we don't
have that duty of care
and is there any support
given to those
who have more difficult problems like
those released from mental health
hospitals
and those released from prison or you
know in custody
do we and want to come back to their
the district do we have that extra
support for them
yes
well i mean
clearly
as i suggested there's a long list of
partners that we work with so i mean i
guess in the right circumstances we
would seek out
support where it was appropriate to do
so i mean i think the key reasons that
people become homeless as i understand
it
relate to
losing private rented accommodation and
that's a particular challenge at the
moment given the high rents that uh
we're experiencing this part of the
country
through
um a family or a family member asking
someone to leave a house
or or actually friends asking someone to
leave a house you know those seem to be
the key reasons why uh people um
uh become a bit bit become homeless um
and the the the the issues that uh i
think council butcher mentions are i
think um quite rare but nevertheless in
the appropriate circumstances if it was
uh something that uh rochford
was involved in we would look to see
what support we could we could provide
wouldn't you regard someone who might be
having to sofa serve as homeless or not
homeless
it's whether they've come forward and
declared themselves as homeless to be
honest so it's hidden homelessness yeah
exactly which we do try to practically
go out yeah
can i just sorry can i just just add one
point actually um just around um
evictions i suppose just to give some
assurance to the committee that
obviously is a housing association i'm
sure i speak for the other housing
associations that operate in the
district obviously one of the things we
really believe in is about
sustainability and tenancy and we will
try to do everything to sustain a
tenancy but it's not always possible but
just to uh to say that um
in 2013 14 we didn't evict anyone at all
and in this financial year we've
affected three households one for
antisocial behavior it was someone who
um previously was in supported housing
then moved into mainstream housing it
probably wasn't appropriate for her
complex needs although obviously that
was the recommendation at the time she
then um assaulted a neighbour she was
imprisoned and that's why she lost her
her tendency um
and two people have been evicted two
households have been evicted for rent
arrears but that's unusual most years we
have evicted either nobody at all or you
know one family or something like that
so i'm sure i shall speak for registered
providers that we try not to add to your
homeless duty by victim lots of people
we try to work with partners just the
same
tendencies now
so um sorry quickly
yes please
it was follow up on council butcher's
question um
in terms of people that
are sleeping on floors i think the term
so
for surfing is a new one to one to me
tonight and i think
okay council council for
that um
and of course there are there is a
phenomenon elsewhere
of
beds and sheds and
i'm
the chairman spoke of hidden
homelessness
and
my question is about have we ever tried
as a council
to
find out the extent
of people that are sleeping on floors
the extent of people that may be
sleeping in sheds
or there are family circumstances where
they do sleep in our buildings
and
to that extent um
if we've surveyed them and we know the
extent of it can you tell us and what we
do to support them
okay
first of all um
i would say that because i
actually volunteer with the deprived
community in the rochester district i
know their social service out there
but they do not
want to declare themselves a sofa
surface and they've chosen to sleep
around their friends
family members um those sort of
circumstances sometimes we cannot make
people come forward
okay we have got a very strong voluntary
community i'm not so sure that i know of
anybody with um
sheds raising your shoes as in sheds yes
um again
we do do each year we go out and we ask
if anybody knows and we reach as many
community groups that we can possibly
reach
um but
perhaps um the the review group could
come up with some suggestions of how
else we could go out to
group
that would be um
yeah
i don't think there's an answer to this
but i'm a little bit concerned about the
one person that has been evicted for
antisocial behavior for
biting their neighbour or hitting their
neighbour
of course i can understand why they
should be evicted and
the antisocial behaviour and being
imprisoned and whatever
but that's the sort of person that i get
a little bit concerned about because
they obviously were in supported
accommodation originally because they
needed it
i would suggest perhaps i don't want to
talk about individuals
maybe some mental health
issues there
put into
general accommodation and it's not
worked would there not be any is there
any support for them having them back
into supported accommodation because
they're still
a resident in our district
as a council with a conscience i would
suggest councillors would
want to support that person yeah and
in some way what they've done is wrong
but
but is there anything that we can do to
support somebody like that well i
believe because the supported
accommodation in this district is very
limited so i believe they are in south
bend they will be working with um you
know we obviously worked with the um the
relevant social services teams and they
will have probation involved so um i
understand they've got into
you know appropriate accommodation in
the south end area and and that's what
concerns me could we
i would like to see some appropriate
accommodation in our district for our
residents that have those difficulties
and as i said with i was talking about
those being released from mental health
hospitals
that perhaps we don't have the supported
accommodation for them and i just
wondered whether there are any
any plans
for us to be providing some supported
accommodation for those
people that do have these difficulties
but i don't know
yeah i mean i would say from our
point of view as a developing
association in the district we would
look um to the council really to say
this is where our priorities are um you
know and for them for us either to
approach them when we have a site or
when we have um a scheme in mind and but
certainly for them also to come to talk
to us if there's specific schemes that
they're looking for that's something
that we could accommodate um you know
sanctuary does has a whole supported
team who develop and support
accommodations so it's something that we
have the skill to to deliver it's then
about availability of land availability
of an appropriate locations the will of
the local authority to support such
schemes and things like that so i think
it's about is there a need for it is it
something politically that that you know
really wants to support and then so
making sure the appropriate
providers and you know are there to
supply it we're also not the only
association that does specialists no
actually that my my comment or question
was not particularly directed at
yourself because um okay there are other
organizations that are available saying
there was the expertise there i think
you know we would just say either when
we've got money available we would come
to the local authority and ask what
they're looking for or we would refer to
your strategy to see sort of where your
needs are
thank you did you say something thank
you chairman i was just saying um
obviously we've only got the one housing
provider here so there are
others to investigate but that might be
another thing for the review to look at
is there a need for supported housing
and if so can it be included in future
developments
thank you um i've got four more people
you want to speak so we'll see how that
goes um
kessler capel and then councillor norman
first so councillor
thank you chairman um i think councilman
makes the point very well the fact that
we cannot force people to
come forward
the best will in the world we can only
offer the services and if they don't
come forward or they don't class
themselves as hands there's nothing
wrong we can do thank you um
two questions firstly we've got any
specific policies around um youngsters
leaving foster care
and secondly following on from council
norman's comments regarding the localism
act i just quickly googled it and
apparently the only thing it involves is
um asking the private rented sector
to work with authorities i don't know
whether the council wants to
expand on that or indeed you do well
that's quite handy thank you
because yes we are um i have to say um
our housing officer who's um
unculturally not here tonight um he has
been working with private
landlords because as
sean explained
the
private rental is extremely high
so he's been working with some
landlords and also looking for some of
them rather than them going to family
going to temporary accommodation we've
actually been paying their deposits up
front which is still worked out more
economical
than putting them into bed and breakfast
but also better for the families which
is the most important thing as far as
i'm concerned
okay
and the other question
oh sorry
obviously um as part of my role i sit on
the children's partnership and we work
closely with the leaving and after care
team
and we have had families before where um
the young person's got to over the
fostering age and the family hasn't
wanted to know them and yes we have
worked with those young people tonight i
thought you might know from these the
other parts of your portfolio thank you
so much
yeah it's more of an interest really and
i don't know who to aim is that but
it's really hazy thing two questions but
thanks for the question about the
localism act because
private tenancy i'm looking at the psl
the public sector lease my area i'm
assuming you would work with that do we
do we have public sector lease where we
get we we take on as an authority
people who own private houses who want
the authority that we used to do that do
we not do that um we um i i know that
sort of chairman we we advertise this um
going back now long before i had the
portfolio and i think the result should
take up or something okay yeah i'm not
aware you haven't got any published
don't fear at all we don't know
okay that's fine
sorry if i just asked a question you
said we did advertise it do we stir it
was um um well as long as my
interpretation of it is the same it was
where if there was private people who
wanted to privately rent out their
additional accommodation their houses
etc they could pass it over to a social
housing landlord who would return it to
them within a set period and um
the same condition
and there was no take-up okay is that
still available to do um it is still
available i think yeah
yeah
because that's an ideal thing for
homelessness it's really really short
term isn't it well it is in short term
that's the thing that they have to sign
it over there
that's right
we've answered that question these are
things and the other thing is it's a
an interest really
um how does the the homeless situation
you say that they're there for a limited
period as per need and eventually some
go because they're not fit or you know
they fit the criteria or you move them
on how does this affect
our waiting list if you like of our
normal housing list now because these
people coming in they're jumping the
queue they come in in a word they're
jumping the line they're coming for
reasons i'm not knocking the reasons or
arguing anything but they're coming they
jump the queue people have been waiting
for years then eventually you say right
they are homeless says we do it we have
the duty to accommodate they're only in
this in a temporary accommodation
what do you do because that must affect
the list and i'm just interested to know
how that works of course it affects the
list
we'll be on that list for years until we
have affordable homes
to accommodate all those people on the
list but can you tell me that's the
question really can you tell me how that
is affected that list in terms of our
housing stock i mean is it a problem
is it just one a year is it all the time
is how does it affect that list
can you can you give me any idea at all
well clearly um you know anybody that uh
is assessed as uh
that that we that uh assessed so to to
so that rockford has a a a duty to house
those people they may very well then
jump to the top of the list so you know
the more people that are presenting and
assessed
uh
in in that way then the less likely it
is that someone that's on the list is
going to get uh is going to get
accommodation you know maybe however way
the process has always worked so i just
want to move on
oh i could suggest that the people who
have been making homeless might have
been on the list but further down anyway
that may be the case
yeah
can that information be provided in any
detail or is that something which is
very subjective
we'll give it some thought and see what
we'll talk about thank you sorry i'm
conscious of time now no i'm just
interested
councilor burton the councilor back and
then councillor segas and then
we have a visiting member who wants
yeah just there's a couple of new
phrases that have come
to my attention tonight like soap
surfers and beds and sheds and things um
the answers that you've given
it seems to me that we as a council are
aware
that there are
a lot more homeless people in the
district than statistics would like us
to
show
not not necessarily a lot more you're
assuming a lot more you just
sorry i just want to well there is more
and
as a council are we confident that we
would actually have enough accommodation
in the district
if everybody wanted
if all those people that we've we've
tried
you know we're saying that we've tried
to approach them
in the past
if they was around and took up our offer
are we confident that we would actually
have
enough accommodation for them
the answer is no
if if if members turn their attention to
the
council's strategic housing market
assessment it will demonstrate that uh
there's a substantial
need for
accommodation affordable accommodation
in in the district and that
is something that has been significantly
helped by the housing uh allocations
that have
been made through the core strategy but
there is still some uh considerable uh
way to go in raw terms
uh you'll you'll probably all be aware
of the figure that's bandied about
generally for the
need needs of new housing uh in the in
in the uk as a whole at
sort of 250 000 new builds a year now
clearly some of that is uh is market
housing a substantial
proportion of that is also
affordable housing um the
uh the total number of houses built last
year i think was 118 000 so they pent up
demand in the current in the current
parliament alone is more than half a
million uh houses across the country as
a whole and that
situation is replicated uh
at local level in terms of the issue of
um of hidden households
you know clearly there are different
types of hidden households if one looks
at the
uh
what's been happening in the last
few years in relation to
glorified
call them what you will um
outbuildings being constructed in
gardens all across the district all
across the south east i think
um
the those are accommodating uh all sorts
of people it may be uh that it may be uh
that you know students have have come
home from university can't get a job and
parents don't want them living in the
house so they built a nice shed in
in the back garden and we've seen that
happening uh time and time again and i
get numerous reports and calls from uh
residents saying what's this going up in
in in the back garden can't you do
something about it no sorry it's
permitted development um so i think
there's a whole range of issues if one
you know expands the the the
the debate about you know housing and
how uh how that works uh and what the
needs uh and and uh are for uh for both
affordable housing and market housing uh
in in the district that helps
the second question um
to be honest it is a question on here
but i'm not sure who's put it forward
but it's not been asked yet um
the facilities that temporary
accommodation provides
how
how is it assessed if somebody came to
you i mean obviously
everybody comes in different
circumstances if for example a family
with young children
came to you and needed
an emergency or temporary accommodation
would you look to put them in
accommodation that
who's visit or what the facilities
match their requirements
chairman it could very well be that the
family will be accommodated in in bed
and breakfast in in that situation that
is the only immediate alternative that
we can offer up in those in those in
those situations that's the most likely
course of so in that situation there's
actually i mean i know obviously there's
providing them with the housing but
there's
not a lot of other support available to
that family
at that time
that it's most likely it would be bed
and breakfast accommodation
um at the moment in temporary
accommodation we've got 42 families
that's too many
this time last year we had 47.
i worked closely with the cab
and in this economic climate
the families that are going to them and
the individuals around um
budgets managing their their money
getting into mortgage you is is
increasing
and yet because they're working
42 42.
because they're working closely now with
these families there's a lot of
preventative work going on so
i'm not happy there's 42
but i am very happy that it's less than
last year especially in this financial
climate and so around that
of the 42 how many would be in bnb
accommodation
um of the
42.13 in b accommodation
but we've we have heard from rochester
housing association that have a vacant
was it one vacant unit at the moment
um you said that in the beginning and we
have um
we have six flexible units so um the
agreement between us and yourselves is
that we have eight units available which
are designated accommodation you can
have up to six others
and um i was using the example that
you'll use in one of our
ex-scheme managers houses at the moment
so i also said an answer to one of the
questions that if you wanted them to
approach us to put a homeless family in
one of our units you would need to make
a decision as a council whether you
wanted to nominate a homeless family
temporarily into that unit or if you
wanted to permanently house someone from
your register and i think that is the
question obviously
sorry for clarification of the 14 units
which are available which you stated
earlier for temporary accommodation
they're all full at the moment
no because six of them are flexible
they're not i don't really think they're
six houses somewhere they are so six of
them because they are they're anywhere
in the district so and if you came to us
this week and we had a property at i
don't know roger garden way bacon and
you wanted it for temporary
accommodation then you could have it for
tempe accommodation so it's not a fixed
unit it's just
wherever it may be
where everyone may be into that so the
difficult decision you have as a council
is if you put someone in that property
temporarily you were then not housing
someone permanently from your waiting
list so i think in roundabouts
it's certainly useful i think you know
if you've got
people with particular needs complex
needs
family size something like that i think
that's probably when we've tended to be
approached in the past for specific
cases rather than
you know as a role
thank you
um
plan yeah thank you chairman um
a few questions that have come out of
the debate on the discussion um first of
all about sofa servers
um
this may be anecdotally but the ones
you've seen are they people who are
young people who are students or are
they are they out of work are they in
work or is there no particular
um if you want to ask me about the ones
i know personally they're the ones that
are under the radar they're not even
registered as neat because they won't
have i i understand that so
they're not but are they in work or are
they not working i'm sorry need means
not in education employment okay okay
understood okay fine
i was wondering why they weren't
interested in applying and and my
guesses were or if they were in work
they might be saving up money and
playing together because that's not the
case mostly
or it may be that they can't be bothered
or maybe they think it's a waste of time
or they may think that the properties
we've got are the interests of them have
you got any thoughts about
why they don't want that yeah
um georgia said all of the above yes
okay and yeah that they will know
families that perhaps
have been on the waiting list for a
while take that as gospel that they're
not going to be a priority possibly um
and also sometimes it fits in with their
lifestyle and it is a choice they've
made okay that's just fine thank you
also i think you mentioned about the
homelessness strategy
and i thought i'd
go onto the council website and very
very quickly it's very it's not nice
about you go straight to housing and you
find a housing the homelessness strategy
very quickly which is actually i think
2011 to 2014.
so we're do you to put a new one up
there yes we are and um
well i've agreed it happened i said it's
just okay now
when i find an old document i like to
look at the end of it and there's a
section of the old mark the future
um it's about in the future now i'll
just pick up one thing there it says um
watchful district council
will need to work closely with essex
county council's
social services department
to ensure homeless young people are
quickly assessed and housed where needed
developing a close working relationship
between the county and district council
will help provide a seamless service
between the two organizations
how do you think that's worked out in
practice um
foreign and i i specifically believe
that in relation to our leaving and
after care team yeah so young people
have been in care yes they have received
a good service through social services
okay um could it be better as with most
services probably
okay let's found
this this is the final comment he was
saying about um the cob helping people
avoid dealing with mortgage arrears and
that kind of thing presumably ev every
time you get something radio about uh
the possibility of interest rates going
up
you must uh
quail a bit because
that's a little real value i guess for
homelessness um
a real um worry for homelessness and the
cab
i'm we're looking to actually commission
some more work from them next year
hopefully um it's early days and we're
chatting to them i say the cab we will
commission an information providing
service
um
but again with the mortgage arrears sean
knows i've already been chatting with
the housing association's looking at is
this an option for us if people are
falling into mortgage arrears then is it
an option for us to pay the mortgage
put a charge to the house because we
will have that back and it gives
stability for that family
but
how many of these families are actually
in their own accommodation a lot as
sean's already pointed out already in
private rental and finding it hard to
reach that it's the
the cheaper rental market that we need
okay thank you
thank you
um
okay
yeah
two or three questions um
mr stratton i think touched upon it a
little earlier when he sort of seemed to
imply that there were suspicions that we
were being sort of shunted
homeless people into this district
rather than the other way around which i
think was a question from one of the
other members um is is that
possibly the case and what checks do we
do to ensure or to ascertain perhaps
probably a better word
whether
those people are already on another
authority's housing list
and
maybe trying to sort of
back an each way bet shall we say
i believe anybody can be in any waiting
list they want to be on yes uh but but
my comment uh and i wouldn't like to
take it any further than that i'm not
sure how easily it would be for us to
determine whether there's any you know
absolute proof that that is the case i
mean it's a
double
uh
interpretation of of just you know
feeling about what what
has has been happening and i wouldn't
put any stronger than that
that's fair enough no what i was really
sort of
aiming at was
um
you know whether we make checks that
they are
actually homeless
in or for this district oh brothers
and how much
effort goes into that i presume it's
quite significant it's yeah i mean the
the the the the assessment of whether
someone uh qualifies to be housed by the
council is is is is it detailed uh and
intensive in terms of the the checks
that that are that are carried out and
it can take some considerable time to go
through that uh through that process
yeah
what would be the uh upshot in the short
term would we be
sort of housing them i would have given
it in
for the time being
until that point
until that assessment is completed
um they would be that if we've accepted
them at the whenever if they turn up at
the uh
at the council's reception uh we will
continue to uh to look after them until
such time as that assessment has been
carried out right um
another question
in view of the
injunction which has been obtained i
believe by harlow and essex county
council
in combination today
are we expecting or prepared for
the possible influx of homeless people
who if they
do not
move
from harlow to
neighbouring authorities
probably closer than rochford is um
are we sort of prepared to actually
accommodate
um an influx of people who could are you
talking about the traveler community it
could be yes
um you clarify what injunction you're
talking about there was an injunction
there was an injunction on the national
news today
which had been granted at least on an
interim basis
by i believe a high court judge or a
judge at least
whereby
all
travellers
or caravans within
the harlow district
have been
served in injunction boarded judged over
a very wide area the whole of that
harlow
district
that
they cannot
reside on
school playing fields verges you name it
the the whole lot is covered
and it does mean that there's a strong
possibility i assume that we will have
within essex because they've some of
them stated they would not be moving
very far
um we may have an influx of
those that are required is that a
question around homelessness though
they say they will be homeless so i
assume that they will be looking to
actually come on to
someone's list
we're a member of the county wide
traveler
they liaise
with all the travelers within the
community harlow won't perhaps if harlow
had they might not have incurred that
problem to start
okay right
thank you um
well then castle mountain council
manchester united member for our
technical interesting members asking
questions thank you thank you chairman
it was a cross between what uh councilor
butcher and council lorman said um
regarding uh the isolated incident of
somebody that's now ended up in in
prison for
attacking
their neighbor or
with the stakeholders involved
at what point um or were their points
obviously this is an escalation in
behavior so
was that person
housed in that location because there
weren't other options available
because it seems like that it was
inappropriate housing um
and had there been sort of a few warning
signs
as the patent behavior escalated and in
hindsight could that person have been
relocated before they ended up in a
prison cell um i i'll pass over to emma
but i i'll have to say and
oh it's working sorry
i have to say that
it
there is a long drawn-out process before
somebody gets evicted i'll pass over to
him and i do apologize my phone has not
been working
yeah i mean as to whether or not it was
appropriate nomination i can't really
answer that question because it would
have been the council who had the
information he then nominated that
person to the property and i would say
without them knowing who the case is and
having that information i don't think
they can then probably answer that
tonight and from our point of view um
yeah it was complex case there was a
mental health issue that was also
addiction there were various other
criminal
allegations and things involved and we
were meeting with the residents to try
and get proof of anti-social behavior
and meeting with the appropriate
agencies
and as to um what tipped off the assault
what happened on you know i don't know
um what tipped off then i don't really
know the history too but i wasn't
directly involved in the case all i can
say is that you know during our you know
our process our investigation we release
it with all the appropriate
organizations
there's one follow-up question yeah
because obviously i think it extends to
the duty of care that we've got on on
both sides of the fence so obviously if
something is being flagged up there may
be an
inappropriate
housing issue how quickly can that be
dealt with
yeah um i think um
sorry
i think sometimes it's about um
the willingness of the person to engage
in the process as well because of course
they have rights so whilst you know we
have people who um aren't in the best
suited accommodation i think there may
be people in shelters for a different
situation but people aren't always
willing to accept they're not in the
best accommodation they maybe don't want
to admit defeat so i think unfortunately
sometimes um if those people you know
won't help themselves really and help
the process or maybe they're not able to
maybe they haven't got the capacity that
makes it a bit more difficult really so
it might have been all the agencies were
involved we were trying to help that
person but actually you know
that was just an issue that was going to
get across
i'm going to ask a question i am aware
that i might or might not know the
answer to these but obviously other
members may not know the answer says
counselor mason's question just just
quickly follow up the thing on which to
capture the mantra was asking about
does the um
housing association uh as he watches
associate employer full-time anti-social
behaviour officer
no we employ um we have quite a small
housing management team but we employ
two um housing officers who deal with
tenancy and housing management issues so
um
they don't deal with rent areas and we
have a specialist team who deal with
rental rates but they would deal with
tenancy issues including asb
and so we have two who work on our
general needs properties and then we
have two who work on our shelter
property and we have 2 000 units and
they'll be trained in asb issues yeah
we're uh um all our staff are trained in
asb but at the moment actually they're
going through b-tech qualifications so
in addition to having the um in-house
training and the policies and procedures
that they already you know always would
have had and following the introduction
of the new asb act in october and we're
training all the staff up to a b-tech
qualification
that's more appropriate than having
a dedicated asb officer which was
obviously the offer document yeah i mean
a decision was taken by the board and it
was it was classified by the board about
um probably about four years ago or
something like that not to have a
dedicated social behaviour officer um
and um you know i think part of the
reason for that is if you have one
dedicated officer on the six weeks off
that they have annually the year and
whatever and those sorts of things
there's nobody else who can pick those
cases up um you know if they're you know
if they're not in the office so actually
the idea was that we would have staff
who are all trained in aspirin so at the
moment they're actually going to uh you
know internationally recognise
qualifications that's what they're
working towards
i think um the case that i've spoken
about tonight very isolated we've had a
number of cases we've taken to court
this year i have to say for asb and but
generally you get a suspended session
order so people are allowed to stay in
their property as long as they um adhere
to the conditions that are set down very
unusual to have that many cases go to
court i have to say
i'm struggling to speak if anyone else
was perfected for asb in our history but
i might be wrong but i don't think we
actually have okay right thank you um
customizing i've just got one more
question
it's a brief question i'm sorry that i
didn't flag it up um you know in our
pre-meeting
um
it came to mind because we've talked
about
mortgage arrears and rent arrears being
a prelude to potential homelessness
and then it occurred to me well of
course we have the phenomenon the sad
phenomenon in this country of food banks
and of course people needing to go to
food banks is another one of these
markers that must be a potential prelude
to homelessness so i'm asking whether
the council's got any any any
information on the extent to which our
residents are needing to
visit food banks and
even if
they're allied to the areas of poverty
that we're aware of
um yeah i can see we've got food banks
in rochefort i can't provide you the
figures now but i can do because i
recently asked that and also how many
people have been referred to them
through from our offices it was a
nominal number um i then found out that
hopeworks provide for castle point as
well which have a greater need so um
but again
the the difficulty is and it is going
back to that preventative
work
it's working with these families about
budgeting
and
priorities what comes first the sky
bill or
the food
and some of the families that and when
you're talking about families and trying
to help them work with them
there are families who will push against
the grain we've got a mediation service
that is free for families so when
they're suffering from antisocial
behavior with another neighbour that's
offered to them for free
some will not engage
so do we get the feeling that you know
food banks are not a last resort they
are in fact you know one of the one of
these pushbacks that you know in terms
of the budget if there's a if there's a
food bank near then people will tend to
use them because they can park part of
their budget in that particular area no
i would um not all at all um and the
food banks in the rochester district are
running under the trestle trasmus model
is everybody familiar with that no i
think especially if you give us a short
explanation but a short explanation is
rather than um somebody just coming and
having a food parcel every week they
actually start to engage that family and
work with them and see what the issues
are it may be
that they are having huge financial
problems they may have lost their job
they may be having a breakdown they may
need a lot of support they may be have
addiction issues
something like that there's a whole
gambit of different issues but the
trussell trust model engages services
that can help them and support them
right
i was going to ask around three things
but i think it's been
i'm sorry
let's just answer
is the trussell trust
uh model widely applied throughout the
country do you know um it's applied in
south end when um a church first
approached me about running it in the
rochester district i linked them into a
church in south and that's run it very
um well for several years
don't have any knowledge about what goes
on elsewhere in the country they're the
biggest nationals
they're they're leading food bank
for another big organisation
and it makes perfect sense if these
families are coming um for
um you know
food parcels that are giving that
support and people have to be
preferred so they can't just turn out
you know so as well as getting the
support you know they will be referred
by an organizer i think it's very
important to the people understand that
people are referred to a food bank you
can't just turn up
um can we just move on from those but um
all i want to clarify about food banks
is
and i'm not sure if
this is what councilman mason
asked or if you put it answered or not
or i might have missed it is that where
people go to a food bank do we do do we
have
or are we able i can understand there
might be anonymous
tea i can nearly say the word there but
do we gather information from that to
help people
if they need help
as a first sign that they may be needing
help
that is the whole idea of the trusted
trust is they build up a relationship
they may need their benefits checked
perhaps they're not receiving everything
that they're entitled to they may need
extra support from the cab and we can
refer them onto the cab we're built up
the partners
happens as much as the people want it to
happen i understand that
right
now george clark i just want to very
quickly ask one a question around
unintentionally or intentionally
homeless
do you feel that
the
the way that we provide accommodation is
based on the fact that people must not
make themselves intentionally homeless
does
do you think this also causes a problem
it may reduce our waiting list or reduce
the duty for us to
provide them as with homes but do you
feel that people are uncomfortable in
making themselves
sorry would you do you feel that people
would be uncomfortable
in being taken to court
over
rent arrears or whatever it may be that
he's making them homeless to make sure
that they're not
making themselves intentionally homeless
it means that they're
incurring their landlording costs
that they can feel uncomfortable with
and those costs mean that they probably
will not be able to get any private
no longer be able to have private
registered accommodation in a way
they're forced to make themselves
unintentionally homeless if you like do
you think that is an issue yes and i i
would like to see that we are grow our
preventative work so it doesn't get to
that stage
but i think it's an important issue um
can you expand on that in 30 seconds one
month
and
basically i've had
been over today which i've been working
with um the chief executive of the cab
and literally saying what do you think
working because they work with a lot
more organizations um
what do you think more can we be doing
or what can you offer to do for us and
work closely with these families
that may come with a price tag it
probably will do but
if they can turn around and say
through this preventative work we can
stop
50 families from becoming homeless
that's what i want to be doing yes
and one final question around housing
lists
roger district council's housing list
has
constraints within it on who
will be provided with homes are you
there i think it's um
i can't remember the exact criteria but
it's um you must have a connection with
the three years in the last five years
you must have a connection with the
district and things around that i
understand that rochester housing
association doesn't have a similar list
and basically they would house anyone
from anywhere within the country if they
met the requirements is that correct do
you think that would have do you think
that actually
causes problems with the homelessness in
the area at the moment
well we have um our register we have 148
people on our register at the moment we
don't have a big register and the
majority of those will be for sheltered
accommodation because our we close our
waiting list to general needs um
family applicants um because you know we
have a different system we have you know
we're not covered by statutes in the way
that you are and so we were able to open
and close our list so basically we've
closed our list say for three bedroom
houses because we've got 19 families on
it now given that
in every four prop three beds that comes
up you will get three of them to
nominate two we will only get one
actually we won't get 19 three-bed
properties in a year so we close our
list we open and close it so it doesn't
get i'm really unrealistically um large
you know because we don't want people
sat there for 19 years expecting to get
a property or
10 years to get a property something
like that so so ours is
you can't say whether it's a true
reflection of demand or not it's 148 it
is what it is it's the majority of that
is for sheltered accommodation
and and yes people can move from outside
the district and to our properties
okay well i think that's it thank you
very much for coming
thank you i hope it wasn't too early
we will
provide
the
list of questions that we want
or would like written i'll give to give
you time so we've got real answers to
them if that's okay we provide those
questions just to make sure that that's
quite clear
and as i always say to members if
anybody's got any other questions around
homelessness um please please do um just
ask and
counselor glenn if you can
give me the details of who you reported
that person to that you saw a reception
that would be wonderful
oh thank you
thank you thank you
can i just slip off it's the tablet
yes
i think i was a little um
i'm speaking in front of sean someone's
not that i have to be particularly
careful but i want to be respectful
um i i was um i was pretty disappointed
that um
some of the base questions that we had
flagged up you know weren't ready to be
answered
but a lot of the information we asked
about to get a feel for you know
the need for preventative work in the
council we need we need some figures and
i think you know
we are going to have in review committee
to consider you know how
we might
um you know fashion a
a way for the council to get that
information for itself
because you can't really do and grow the
preventative work till you know we're
actually looking at yeah
that's interesting
i don't i don't know your questions be
answered yeah but i genuinely feel
that there was an awful lot of what was
said
from
visitors that actually was a
a smoke screen
because they didn't know the answers and
we're not involved in it now i genuinely
feel that in future we really need to
have a group maybe two or three people
that part of their
time at work
is to sort out all this to do with
homelessness and that because we in my
opinion it's just
although we've got it there and
everywhere else has got it but roxford
everybody thinks we don't have much at
all that we all know every one of us
have people in our own area
that have major problems and i really do
feel that we should not be smoke screen
tonight
i'm sorry
yeah i i'm i'm concerned about the smoke
screen because
in fact we didn't
i mean we had the portfolio holder here
who
obviously
has got a lot of knowledge around this
and and and i would assume as perhaps
got some concerns as well
and maybe we didn't actually ask the
question what concerns do you have
about
the homelessness situation because
i think you know we had some some honest
answers there and i think there are some
concerns i mean a couple of things that
i did pick up she said
maybe we ought to be looking at do we
need supported accommodation
and
um
did emphasize some of the preventative
work so perhaps that was an indication
from the portfolio holder that maybe
that is what
she is concerned about but
but perhaps we should have just asked
her and
she's got the knowledge and you know
asked straight out what what did she
know and i think it's quite clear that
she asked that or did suggest that some
of those subjects would be suitable for
us to look at as well
so i think
that that was there
so maybe you know with these questions
we're sending her perhaps we can ask
what support yeah and how she feels okay
it's very good point
yeah
sorry kessler norman sorry i'll just
pick up the year it's just very very
quickly going
from my perspective it's purely my
perspective where in my
little knowledge is a bad thing
sometimes is i don't fully understand
and it's about me really but i to get
into this i don't fully understand
because of the
separation of housing from councilman
you know whereas before it was a council
property you know what i mean
um
how this is all worked out who who who
makes all the decisions about who goes
up to a housing is who does this is
there a department i mean i don't fully
understand how that works yeah i think
that's
fine i think we have to get your
machinery i don't know if you need to
visit the department yeah i don't you
need to visit your partner yeah you need
to speak i accept that but well that's
the problem i'm having is putting that
together but i think that should be done
outside
so
sean could arrange that sure
definitely it's all about nomination
right so there is a close relationship
between the council and uh and housing
associations and uh the council has uh
has priority nomination rights uh to the
uh to the housing association
of how that process works what i was
gonna say was if i may there was brought
up there about this anti-social
behaviour thing which is a thing for me
but
about
behaviour etc
um
they've only got part-time we have only
got a part-time
uh asb coordinator stuck in the police
station so i don't see where his link is
from a council perspective into housing
he couldn't get further away and then in
their perspective they're saying i'm
training my officers out well you are
they're going to be
distracted if you like because of all
the other commitments about what is
antisocial so they're going to be
limited and not just that question about
so you're adding
the relationship okay but if i have if i
take up the offer first before i'll go
into that yeah
yeah right it might be really
thirty
just briefly um
some
two or three months ago i think there
was a an email came round to us all
asking
um
you know for our sort of thoughts on
homelessness and
what criteria ought to be applied um
whether we should adjust our
criteria at all
um and if so in what way
but uh
is that still in process or
jim there is a there is a there is a
report on the key registered in the key
decisions list
that proposes to make changes in the in
the arrangements
let them come before council
how many there will be
coming through that side foreign me
we'll have that arranged to everyone
tonight yeah
we've just been asked about how many
housing associations there older we're
living with how many have we got in
brighton district yeah well we're last
outside the meeting i think because i
really want to move on to the next
subject
income
do i need to apologize for not attending
a pre-meet uh john uh racing actually um
referred to a pre-meet during the
discussion
i'm
they are that little bit earlier i don't
understand how people work i mean it's
not always possible
um
car park income so we've had the
report
which is recommended
yeah let me note um i think that's the
black yeah interesting first of all
councils have to review themselves and
how they vote on things and uh
i i i was against increasing the charges
because i thought you wouldn't do much
of income and the effect that i think so
that i was wrong with that clearly
because incomes went up and number of
people coming in from that club
on the other hand i was writing to vote
against
abolishing stuff in the afternoons
because i think it's been proven
we can manage the council quite well and
still keep free city afternoons um but
apart from that very interesting
the figures if you look at the breakdown
uh over the time periods i think it's
fair to say they're all over the place
aren't they some are higher some were
lower
as to why and i wondered in particular
if you had any information about how
saturday mornings are doing
as opposed to the rest of the week
but that's just my thoughts and
questions really
all right
i don't know if uh
someone's got any answers to
any thoughts on that um
my impression is the saturday morning i
do i do very well but i mean i can uh
you know i can provide
a breakdown saturday morning so you'll
provide a breakdown of saturday
afternoons as well please
that would be a bit difficult
don't pay i am do see an awful lot of
people paying on saturday afternoons
yeah
and during saturday mornings in december
as well yes um you know i've done that
let's just just show that if we do have
an epidural information on saturday
morning afternoons that will be
interesting
yes
obviously spent more time looking at
this and there's an eye he alluded to
the fact that the um the time bands are
kind of all over the place could he just
point me to where he'd like to ask mr
scrap particular questions
well
i've really in terms of saturday
afternoons which aren't the chance so
saturday mornings right here but if you
look for example
um 30 minutes a lot more tickets have
sold
uh up to one hour my tickets sold
one to two hours
a lot less tickets sold
um
i think it's quite clear isn't it
there's there seems to be a
large larger number of people or tickets
being sold for under an hour yeah and
then it's
sort of one to three hours yeah
yeah and then the longer ones are going
up yes yes so
i mean maybe people are popping you know
either popping in quickly going away
quickly or they're staying longer
and you know maybe maybe
maybe some cafes people are i'm not
saying that they're either going quickly
and going away again or they're staying
i think having a coffee something
you know when we advise on on issues
around uh
uh car parking uh tariffs um
one of the things that
we look at very closely is what the what
the unintended consequences might be
from making changes and sometimes it's
difficult to
fully uh gauge what those might be and
uh you'll recall that you know we always
seek to try and address those in uh in
the risk assessments in in any report
but i did i did notice just as an aside
i noticed that the traders in leon c
seem to be up in arms now that actually
the losing trade as a result of the
fact that the
on-street parking arrangements have
changed from one hour uh no return to
two hours
and and i just thought that was quite
interesting um that you know there's a
change that had taken place
uh you know and and i think probably
called for by the traders um and
actually they're now saying they wanted
reversed uh because they they think it's
had an adverse impact and it's just an
example of how
important it is to try and get the uh
these arrangements right so that you do
get the uh the turnover of car parking
in the car parks and you you know the
trade traders do get the uh
the uh the custom uh that they that they
require to be uh successful and viable
okay um
with a 30 minute to one hour crisp
speeds are a lot of bit now it's gone up
to a pound
uh for an hour and fifty pounds a lot of
people very often don't have 50p so they
just put the
pound
i've got some indications uh all i'll
say is i'll take visiting members last
heads if i just say they're aware um
yeah purely just only the amount of
extra car parking places they put
especially in
the in the main entrance and down bolton
way it's absolutely amazing
in the last month how all these new
tickets are coming in to be so where you
could sit and watch out to the river now
you've got to pay to do it and that's
the area that i think we're not involved
in that in any shape because we haven't
put any more extra um parking uh places
in rockford to pay for everywhere that
we've got it's been there for some time
and it is quite different to south end
thank you
burton
um it's not really a question it's just
an observation really um
i think my view looking at this video
i'm not surprised
that
income's gone up that's why i was
introduced it was introduced to make the
council extra money and that's what it's
done quite simply um with regards to the
sales of tickets
you know there's there's an increase in
houses being built in the district so i
think there will be a natural increase
in tickets with small houses more cars
and really these figures aren't that
much of a surprise i don't personally
think i think it's
quite unnatural
fees have gone up the number of cars
have gone up
um yes i think i'd echo
councillor burton's sort of comments
that
in terms of the actual ticket sales
um it's remarkably stable through
through
the comparable period uh the previous
year
i'm just wondering whether
some of the apparent anomalies in the um
sort of allocation of tickets 30 minutes
to 30 minutes to one hour one to two
hours etc
there might be some sort of arbitrage
going on there
in terms of
the way in which people may be
arranging their visits and payments
i can't recall all of the hourly charges
or the different banned charges
but
is that possibly some
reason for the
apparent disparities in in the way that
people are staying
it could be
that's probably as but as much as i can
say and people do
uh look to see um you know how they can
pay the minimum fee
to
to park and do the business that they
need to do so
i think um we probably need to know more
about which car parks
as well maybe it's liverpool i think
it's possibly quite interesting it might
to my mind it might be indicating that
the
high street is changing and perhaps in
rockford and rayleigh that we're getting
into more of a
um
service sector if you like with people
either popping in very quickly to do the
banking or something very quickly
with i'm not going to say fewer shots
but perhaps
maybe less of a shopping experience and
they'll get in other places
but then they're saying longer because
they're going out for a
lunch or a meal um
there's getting the balance right in the
town center in terms of you know retail
versus other other uses is really quite
important i think in the in the modern
world now and you know people are
looking for for more of an experience i
think rather than just
popping in to uh to to a shop and
leaving though that still
clearly clearly happens but people are
looking you know to visits to be more of
an event i mean one of the interesting
things is and it's it's you know it's
not just it's not a dramatic increase i
guess um in relation to the total
the total income but i mean clearly
mobile phone transactions are
are
beginning to grow and what's interesting
about that i guess is that um if if you
pay by mobile phone um
you're not under the same pressure to
depart as you as you might be uh if
you've put some some cash in in the
machine because the mobile phone will
your mobile phone will will
will um will warn you when uh your um
your payment is due to expire and ask if
you want to add some more money so um
you know it gives a um a bit more flair
now i've used that uh on occasion not in
in this district but elsewhere you know
and it gives you more flexibility in
terms of your in terms of your uh your
your visit so it'll be interesting to
see how that that develops over the next
week well
um you've got counselor
um mason for the black house
and then
i i just want to dig up what councilor
burton and councillor said
general
ascent to this
conclusion that the more houses you
build the more cars there are
therefore there are more visits
and therefore there's more income and we
should expect that to to happen however
we've only got a finite capacity in our
car parks
now i've been to raleigh on a saturday
morning it's quite rare i've got to i've
got to tell you but i've actually found
that car park very nearly full
and i'm actually thinking i've actually
seen hopley
very nearly full as well and that's the
near the they're the two nearest ones to
me um rocks would i don't frequent as
often and it's probably during the week
and visit for council but my my question
is to the what extent is the council
actually looking at
these additional houses generating
additional car journeys local car
journeys for shopping have we got the
capacity in the car
yeah that's a question
is it a question right it's related
there was some talk some years ago about
building a multi-storey car path from
webster as well
additional spaces
i suppose
um
it's interesting isn't it i suppose
um the answer is yes and no to to the
respective you know comments that have
been made in the sense that i i guess if
if
some of the
uh
some of the cars from new housing
determine that they're going to
uh use car parks for a longer period
that might actually mean that the the
car parks are fuller you know i don't
think there's probably very much
capacity at the
quick turnover
and but you know if if if uh if some of
the if that makes sense you know because
if the
um
and there may be more or more people
thinking well we'll stay for a bit
longer you know and uh i don't know it's
an interesting question and i can
contemplate it further if uh
if if you if you'd like i think you'll
be good but there is a finite capacity
and i think that's the key probably the
key point ultimately
in
this
yeah i think you were going around i
think it's a great question i think
thank
casa berson for starting with councilman
it's a good question from council but i
don't agree with this premise really i i
don't i don't think
that the increase in the population
district
has been enough to cover the increase in
car parking i think in the long term you
look at that um
the
but also
all i've been hearing the last five ten
years is that the high streets are all
doomed we all want to be going out of
town and
buying online and
which is good i think um and that's
starting to work um but but i think he's
right about in the long term you've got
to think about these things um somebody
mentioned about the the
non-historic car parking idea for the
newest members
we had some consultants who to be fair
to them basically said the only thing
you could do
is put a multi-storey car part of a big
with a big store or monster spray car
park but we don't really recommend it
that's how it came up and no counselors
liked it
um
the
what struck me though
in all the figures
that maybe goddess one is that was
almost
the number of people staying all day is
almost up this back by almost a third in
one year
and i'd be just to see the figures from
the previous year to see whether
the
13 14 was an unusually low low year for
that was that that is that's what you
could explain in terms of shopping
people changing their habits coming not
going but staying all day
is that what is
that okay
i think all day prices did not go up did
they no yeah how much are they sorry i
think they have something weird going on
with the approach yeah
how much that is the approach
um well the approach car park has uh got
a reduced daily
fee um and and that has resulted in a
significant
increase in its usage
um
but by thousands would you say
i don't have the yeah i
yeah the average price is less than that
anyway so the approach is obviously
significant if you work out the average
cost on the order to get as well well
under five pounds she's under five pages
yes
i'll keep it very short
just something you said about that um
just thinking about it i know and you
will know
residing in love line yes that
the parents of love lane school have
been extremely actively encouraged not
to park
in love lane or the surrounding roads
anymore and
there's been a big increase in
parents of bloodline using the car park
in the mornings and after school to drop
and pick their kids up
i've said that you mentioned that trying
to come here tonight there was a queue
of about 12 class parked in love lane
you supposed to get through so that
might account for something because i
know that there's a lot of parents are
using that now
okay
it's just just right today um
the what they call it they're trying to
cry yeah
these put a child yes because of love
lane because everybody's bulking in its
car
as far as the
impact of new housing is concerned
if we are
achieving
approximately the 250 houses per year
that represents still to my
very rough
calculation probably about point six
percent of housing stock there's an
increase so i think it would be having
an infinitesimal
impact on on these numbers whereby
sort of areas such as great white cream
for instance don't have any public car
parking other than on the roads um
so
you know
it it
it
would
actually dilute that number even further
in terms of the actual
amount of extra car parking which would
be occurring
um
and the other thought which i had was
i wonder whether five pounds a day
is actually a bit of a bargain relative
to
um some of the um
station car parking within the district
i think you might have brought up before
just to give you some information the
average price per ticket
on the
august january the bottom table is three
pounds eighty-seven
for the previous year the average price
but it gets four pounds three pence
both been under five pounds so the
approach is
that's it i'm a player in that i was
thinking particularly in terms of
all-day car parking that's the all day
when i was talking about oh right yeah
okay so the average price is well below
and that's pulled down because of the
approach that will i suspect be a great
deal cheaper than an annual parking
season at the stations
but they don't like using it
it's not used there's a house that
overlooks the station car park i can
tell you there's
100 200 spaces every day that's used
strange
sorry um we're drawing this one so close
cancel the mountain thank you patiently
thank you for letting me come in uh it's
a question really for the review
committee i guess uh in my mind if i'm
correct the the
reason for the increase was to
plug a gap of about 60 000 pounds i
think we were told that was the reason
to increase charges now clearly it's
it's done uh
it's making a lot more than that needed
amount
and i wondered whether there could
perhaps be an argument now for
um
giving something back in terms of
making it free parking after 6 pm
perhaps or
making it free parking
all day saturday and whether that would
have
we would still be within the the needed
60 000 because clearly we're way over
because of that thank you
i mentioned before but i thought
stopping paying at six p.m would be a
good idea it would help the early
restaurant trade and i i would support
that
i think saturday morning's probably
is a bit too is a bit too far because
it's pretty busy there already um it
if you have it for something
it will discourage turnover so i i will
keep saturday afternoons saturday
mornings
free it's like saturday mornings pay
i wondered about we have three saturday
mornings
for four dates before christmas
yes and i wondered if that if that's
worth extending even if it's only
for maybe one saturday or two after
christmas for new year's sales well
that'd be a good idea i've always wanted
to raise it but of course it comes up as
an urgent item
it always catches the council off guard
christmas
and
you know if you would he felt it it was
worth
having
and a couple of three saturdays after
christmas i would certainly be very
happy with that i think um personally i
think that's an interesting point i
think
i'm happy for that to be on the ripple
to look at yeah um i'd be happy for the
two january two days in january because
i thought that would be a good idea as
well
i'd also agree after 6 p.m
and i'd also personally like looked at
the
provision of blue badges free parking
at least in some of our car parks which
they currently do not have apart from
that initial hour
ticket i don't know how the
members agree with all those items
so counselor i certainly fully
agree with the two saturdays after
christmas because a lot of people coming
to raleigh for the sales
and and it really is
in my opinion it's a damn good idea
because instead of people going further
afield they come into railing and it's a
nice place to be as you all rightly know
people now stop and have a drink and
everything else so i think that would be
excellent but the other point which you
came up with was uh
what was the other thing you just said
after 6 p.m
yeah everyone said it not just me but
yeah but after 6 p.m each night
there's not many people that actually
unless you're going to the doctors
and i'm talking about rockstar with back
lane um and there aren't any um
car park attendants around at that time
of night
i've never caught one there and i think
six o'clock to finish would be a good
idea or even 6 30.
i think that you know because of the
yeah that last hour a few people
actually put their money in anyway
i don't want to talk about the options i
was about how he handle it yes um
you know we we could just simply minute
this
um these ideas and pass them over to the
portfolio holder or the executive and
let them make their own decision
however that doesn't involve ourselves
in that and clearly these are ideas come
from this committee
so i wonder if we could extend an
invitation to the portfolio holder and
and mr scrutin to come back to the next
um review committee
um having considered these um
these points that have been made so that
we can you know hear um what the view
the portfolio holder is and maybe
you know get the opportunity to come
back because otherwise we won't yeah i
think
that's good idea and they and
it would be possible then for costings
for those ideas to be
obtained yeah which will
make make it
easier to discuss is that acceptable to
the library
yes okay
right thank you
thank you very much
just have a minute to
thing and there's there are particular
questions that people you know having
read the report haven't haven't actually
you know got an understanding of could
we not move to the recommendations and
look about whether or not we're in
agreement
um
so i'm just so confirmed that everyone's
happy with the parking that we've
discussed yesterday
right yeah i wouldn't like to to make
any sort of recommendations here i'd
like to get the
finances um
okay um
all right
good report
just move straight to recommendations
and we'll run through those quickly so
if you haven't got any
issues problems or additional questions
around those as we go counseling
yes the bloodshed digit matters it took
many months to decide what it was going
to be called and the number of times
people sat in this room and discussed
what it was going to be it went on from
now to eternity and before it came into
being but um and i've always been
pleased that we have it
but um and i think if you actually
changed it um you've got to look at it
but if you're going to change it you
change it after when 16 comes when the
council changes completely if you want
to call it something different then do
it to come in in 16 when the new
council's performed
okay that's my only comment we're going
to start at the top yeah i was going to
go go back yeah
i've got the question
that's not
recommendations
i think it's excellent because a lot of
old people that are not like me now
because i've got one but to be perfectly
honest there are a lot of people
especially older people in that that
keep it to look for the dates and
different things and i think it means
well you need something to put your
potato peelings in well
no they go out to the case right item
two the readership of the online version
of rdm is reviewed on an annual basis
which i yeah i think yeah
do
do we know who reads it i i don't know
how we can review that we can review the
distribution
numbers
and we can obtain
stats from that i will show them through
the
online online
things
on the online
item three
which is one cass lagoon spoke on the
residents being encouraged to suggest a
new name for the paper kessler mason
chairman i i
i i really encourage um the committee to
you know
be positive
and adopt this recommendation um
i'm sorry
um
the name roster district matters has
become significantly discredited
in the district it's a little bit of a
laughingstock because people actually
call it rotara district doesn't matter
and to be quite honest with you i am fed
up to my back teeth for reading it and
hearing it
i think it needs a new name to get rid
of that discreditation that has happened
i i don't have any record of such
comments made to me put it that way
and i i i cannot accept that uh that is
the widespread case
sorry castle yeah i mean in terms of
discrediting from mine in the district
although i i haven't heard that phrase
council mason
a lot of people in roth don't get it
you know he misses out a significant
part of the palace
in distribution i don't know
i don't know why but they don't see that
um
this this is something which needs to be
taken up with uh the royal mail in that
case then because they have the contract
to distribute it and the
main
problem with uh the distribution
this time last year whatever was simply
that the contractor was not up to the
job
and that's why it went back to royal
mail as i recall
if there are those that are still not
receiving it
if they need you know those areas need
to be reported
to uh i forget the name of the officer
involved but um
it was laura bliss yeah i had a sneaky
suspicion
and certainly when
i believe
we had some email correspondence in the
dim and distant past yes i did forward
that query too indeed you did yes
and
as far as i know that was taken up
um she certainly said that it would be
taken up with with the royal mail if
there were still
folks
not receiving it but of course
they can only do if they deliver one to
each household
it doesn't mean that every member of the
household sees it so if someone there
decides they're going to bin it before
x y and z have seen it yeah
they'll go down and say oh we've never
seen that
you know who knows right
i think
just to literally just talk for a very
quick minute on this the reason
as part of the working group for this
um
project as well
the reason the recommendation was to
make to keep it in paper format was
because the online relationship just
isn't
successful we're talking about the name
of the world however
generally watchful district matters as a
publication isn't
received particularly well by resident
and i think past possibly just because
recommendation three is where it is if
you actually looked at four and five
you would see that the idea behind this
was to refresh the publication as a
whole
and that involves making some other
changes first and possibly
that's why we're suggesting the name
change
because there's no point making the
modifications to a publication and then
bring it out with the same name so
thanks
for watching
yeah i was actually going to say um
what you said but it was also going to
say when we were talking about
distribution i believe we talked about
uh with the extra
copies that are printed distributing
them into um
into doctors and
uh
other public areas so that so that there
are more available throughout the
district rather than being sat indoors
or something in some offices
it wasn't one that came out in the end
but they're already doing it anyway
i know they're actually putting it out
to the some of the gp surgeries in the
libraries right okay
spencer
and then
is there any way um
it's like
the free papers
every so often you'll get a phone call
to ask you whether you've received it
and it's all done at random
that's the only thing that's going to be
done that's the auditory circulation
which i've been told is very expensive i
i wasn't within this i've asked you some
years ago about do we have autistic
circulation figures that said no because
it is far too expensive and that's what
the telephone calls are
sorry quickly yeah just touched on that
subject and that was raised at the the
review and
i counted i understand on one side is
that
rdc staff
are asked
to confirm whether or not they've
received obviously living all over the
district and i think councillors in the
last time it was distributed i think we
were last to report back
now obviously that's not as
comprehensive as employing a company to
audit those checks and
and keep everything but it's a start and
it's a way that we as councillors and
staff rdc can help to identify whether
or not certain areas are being missed
that's right
castle
no it's just a question for me i'm not
being privy to a lot of this stuff that
goes on but um
we keep talking about it's not being you
know received very well but do we know
what of this document is not being
received why i mean what is it in this
package that's not
coming across is it is it just the
format is it the content is it the
presentation i mean i don't know and i
haven't heard that yet what is it that
isn't any good that's the question i
think um maybe
caitlyn could answer that whether she
checked that yeah i mean
we discussed all elements of this
clearly the name as we've heard gets
played upon in a couple of different
ways people um
aren't particularly happy at seeing
events which have happened they want to
know about events which are going to
come about they want it in a more
orderly format a lot of people cut
certain bits out to put on the fridge
for information but they need to go oh
this is future events this is something
about something else very much more
organized it's
big and cumbersome it comes in folded in
half quite often he's picked up and
shoved with the free papers never to be
seen again it needs to jump out
it seems to us to be quite tired and
dated
and he's got a lot of really good
information
if you can get the people to read it
and our thoughts was you need to get
them to read it to pick it up and go oh
great this has come through let's see
what's coming up in the district not a
load of photos of things that have
already happened
so it was a whole package that were
already intrinsically linked to the name
the size the way it's laid out
i accept that uh that
obviously it makes sense
uh where in all of this uh who is
responsible for rejecting all this oh
putting this all together you know like
to redesign if you like
how has this worked out you had an
officer that did it well we've got
stunning paul's probably better places
basically what happens once the
recommendations go forward to go forward
to the portfolio holder who will discuss
with the officers who is that
councillor lucas
right
to decide which of the recommendations
she feels are workable
and she wants to implement and then
she'll do that and there'll be a report
to come back a portfolio holder decision
to sort of link up
with the decision or the recommendations
you've made and the decisions she's come
to on those so what i'm saying sorry so
all these recommendations are all these
bits of this
new document if you like does that not
come back to review for you to or your
group to have a look and say yes we then
go down to you
that's what's done that's why you're
here now to do the recommendations
more than anything
nothing to redesign if you like it
doesn't come back to anybody
onto the portfolio without anybody
agreeing with you
am i right
are we both right that just one person
in the finish or just one person that
says yay or no and the rest of everybody
else can go and no i'll be very ladylike
and just say that in my opinion
what happened years ago and um i know
chris hit me on my head but it was a
group of people
that
came with the ideas and i would like to
think if this is going to be changed
it's going to be changed from 16 it
should have a right cross cut party look
at it not just one person okay um
should be considered together
i
i council seekers must be i just want to
come in after he spoke with that's all
not if anyone else will speak can they
indicate now
right you've spoken twice counselor
seekers
um
are we now still considering just ice
and three at this point i think we
should consider i think
we seem to have drifted from
you know thinking about rebranding with
a new name
which i could suggest one which is
that district just outside south end
matters
as as a equally appropriate one to
something different to rochford district
matters
and which i think sums it up um
it's what it's you know what it says on
the tin
in terms of the
content
i think there are possible difficulties
here in that if we don't include
the
things which we have achieved as a
council then we'll be accused of never
having achieved anything
um so i think it's you know occasionally
we do need to grow about things we have
achieved as a council which by and large
has seemed to have been punching above
its weight
and in terms of the practicalities of
that content
i suppose it's possible that putting
a smaller format with more pages
together would enable the
sort of fridge magnet requirements to be
more easily assimilated but i'm not
quite sure how that would always
necessarily fit with
the
actual variation in content
areas should we say in terms of
things which um you know
one issue you might have a lot more
about
wonderful great wakering
and the next it would be wonderful rock
roll ref
new uh
new town but um
it it would be
i think difficult to be consistent
with the total volume
in each section
if you really wanted to make it
relatively straightforward to
put together and this is going to take
quite a bit of office of time it
probably already takes quite a bit of
office of time but it's probably easier
on an ad hoc basis
within that larger format whereas as
soon as you start coming down saying
we've got to have x number of pages for
each segment that we've decided to set
up however they split whether it's by
geographic split or
topic
um
of a particular portfolio uh area etc
you know that tends to vary greatly from
issue to issue
sometimes there are seasonal matters
which
need to be kept in there on a regular
basis other times
a specific problem arises or some new
policies is introduced which hopefully
we
the majority of us will agree on
um
those are the sort of initial comments i
i have on that
so i think that probably covers a fair
bit of three four and five four yeah i
think it does um
come down yeah thanks chairman um we
weren't for one minute suggesting that
we didn't um
blow our own trumpet sort of thing out
of our achievements i think that came
about because there was a very lovely
photo of the chairman of the council at
an event that had already happened
and a lot of people never knew about the
event to start with that's right so the
comment was that's great to see her
but we would have rather have seen last
year's chairman at last year's event
enjoying it so we knew to be able to go
to this year's
and that it's more the social events
going on the wild woods day the things
like that even the things that the
parishes
run
that
a lot of people want that to be
a section so they can go to their paper
and say right whatever front pages that
would change
right i know i can get my recycling
calendar i know i can get my calendar
meetings i know i can find out what is
going on
completely across the district from
fairs faiths wild woods etc and then the
rest of the paper whatever but they know
these would be
quite static things it wasn't not saying
how we done well
it was not having these social things
that people then go that was nice but we
didn't know what's going to happen
so you want you want basically a
calendar section in there yeah in a way
because what's the blood section
well a lot of feedback was
we didn't know these things were
happening perhaps we didn't look at the
paper we didn't see in any detail we're
now focused in because there's a great
photo of the chairman in the woods
but we've already missed it
and that should be more
publicizing this was last year's
chairman at this great event and this is
coming on in a few weeks time
um because that hones the eye in where
it was just a list doesn't necessarily
on the assumption that it is a um
annually repeated event at the same date
and a lot of things weekend whatever
yeah a lot of things are that we have
for example wildwoods
that's what that comment about
and
yeah
councillor lawrence councillor mason
then council again yeah thanks very much
just on that
i was a good answer i just copped up as
you were talking but to me i thought the
old point well i don't know because i
wasn't near the beginning but to me i
was under the impression that the this
paper was really it's a it's a link
between us and our residents and it was
an informative way of informing our
residents if you like about us you know
it's a document about the rochefort
district council i would have thought
it's not a newspaper is it and is it
going to be factual is it going to be
personalized
so i mean
who you know what i mean i mean is it
just going to be a
a comic if you'd like to tell me all my
timetables and all this so well we can
have this flexibility of a personality
anyway that's just a comment what i
wanted to do it was a question i wanted
to ask that was well started
um
question four the size of newspaper
would reduce to 320 but i don't know
what that is can someone tell me 13 by
10 the chord are probably full scap we
reckon
an a4 size
i think it's probably four
goals
larger than that
320 millimeters it's roughly
simply because some people have a
problem reading a small print
and if you start condensing things down
you start reducing the size of what
you're looking at that was my only
comment that's why i was asking what
that is yeah
call it a foot roughly that's the only
reason i'm so full is probably about the
right size
um just to figure out what are your
points counselor lauren uh eric pickles
of dclg you've probably heard of him
yeah made it quite clear that um council
newspapers whatever you call them may
not compete with the
local newspapers that are paid for to do
so would find you probably in some
difficulties so that's why we can't okay
um
i spoke about number three i think there
should be a new name yeah
if it goes well as councillor burton
says with the other changes then that is
another reason to do
um the council's got three press offices
that cost us a fortune they spend enough
time and enough money
writing about the achievements the
wonderful achievements
of our council
they post them to at least 100 places
every time that they write one and from
the pieces of the media i read
enough of our achievements are blown
at the time when they're made to re
repeat them several months later i think
is a total nonsense
2016 council councilor glenn i don't
agree it should be done now
um and in terms of resident engagement
hey what a really good idea
if you engage the residents in it they
might not think that it's something that
doesn't belong to them and it's
something being put on them so i'm happy
with three four and five and six thank
you okay
castle clean yes
i'm on the hospital foundation again
which i came off and then come back and
i've always asked every time that the
foundation are going to have a public
meeting particularly over mill hall or
somewhere in the district and it's in
the future that it goes into rockford
matters for people to see that they can
go to a meeting
of the foundation to learn about what
goes on at south end hospital and i
would like to feel there's
other organizations like that that can
put their advert in
to say this is coming as you rightly say
two or three months in advance and i
feel that if there was a column like
that it would be very useful for a lot
of people that don't go out a lot but
they're interested in it for argument's
sake with the hospital and they come 80
hundred people come to me along to that
meeting but that's that's basically
through what's what matters i think that
comes under resident engagement i think
doesn't happen i don't know but
it really is a good thing
and there are other organizations too
that should be
futuristically put down i was going to
start did were you indicating cancer
first of all i was just going to say the
recommendations that we're making are
nothing to do with content it's the
content's going to stay
i don't think it was a comment largely
the same well it's just going to be put
into defined sections the readers can go
and focus in on what they want to read
and not have to juggle between sections
i think it's very good i think council
about the ability to things being in
there i think content would change if
residents get involved personally but
we'll see casa butch
just very quickly um i mean there was a
lot of conversation
in our group around this
and one of the main things that we sort
of came to a conclusion is the editorial
group team
need to have that final say
in the editorial because there are legal
implications there are things that can
and can't be done
we didn't want to be saying you will do
this or you will do that we've got to
leave it to the editorial team that
we're we employ to do that job okay
thank you um
a bit more contentious than i thought
that would be
very briefly
further question um where did the 320 by
260 millimeter figures come from they
don't appear to be any sort of standard
size of
paper it came through within the report
i can't report pages on here certainly
was it the minimum
size they were able to do basically
the exposure to the printers
and that was the size they could
actually do
with the
the certain paper size they got at the
moment and they could
cut it to that size without any further
cost
right and district and the reason for
that is innate it's 6.9 in that it
wouldn't then be mistaken for one of the
three it would be distinctly different
in size from one of the three papers on
as i understand it correct
and royal mail would be prepared to
deliver
which again would still be able to
deliver it it it fitted all the criteria
and it didn't cost anything more
that's fine okay so that that was
okay last one has slipped okay um have
we looked at any publications issued by
other accounts
oh yes
if you've ever received the southwark uh
um sort of full colour
probably 14-inch or so thick
magazine which comes out promoting
southwark and all its business
sort of schemes um i'm about to send a
freedom of information act to them to
find out how much each of those copies
costs and how many they issue to get the
total cost to them
because it's got to be
fabulously expensive if they're still
sending it to me as the former um
finance and resources portfolio holder
from over two years ago now
well we looked at numerous publications
from
neighbouring authorities um from the
parishes including the broomstick which
council burton found particularly
engaging
which is
um moved to
do we need to move to a vote for this
proposal i think that some
people aren't over them
sorry one at a time yeah
um
we're taking one at a time i think just
threes we'll go through so um do
we have agreement on item one
if
i'll go through to say agree if you
disagree with us he described item two
of three
three three yeah
is that one person disagree
yes
that's five everyone else agrees yes yep
item four
agreed
okay
any decision document there isn't a key
decision
at the moment
so that while you have body papers right
mate
item nine
is the work plan
you have one month to go
the reviews committee's annual report
i will be pointing my
fall in my forward to
pull very shortly
i was going to add we've now given
ourselves card parking in there
just to come back on so that that would
be interesting i'm not going to let
anything else be added to that um
i'm not sure if this is my place to
mention this but we are
also
um
so all the other ones have been done and
we'll have the report to come back from
homelessness hopefully already report
some sort
maybe
i think we're asking them back now
i think so i think
we obviously got
answers to some things yeah which of
course you know can be can be recorded
there are other things that they're
going to provide us information
um i'd hope they wouldn't just send me
an email as individual members
of the committee but they go through
through paul
um to to incorporate in a more overall
review of the facts that have been found
i think
that those facts that have been found
need to come back to this review
committee so that we can decide what we
do next yeah and i'd like that for the
full team i think
um
i'd also like
people to put their minds
which i've also mentioned other people
but they might spot
they think should be put on
i know we're not
myself or anybody here might not be on
this review for you next year because we
normally put forward issues that should
be we think should be being considered
next year
okay
yes 2-1 9.3 and if we don't do something
about potholes
i'm a dutchman that's my failure
that's what it's my failure
and the potholes that are
on unadopted road is a disgrace we all
pay our fees and everything else we get
nothing
and i think it's something that should
come up yeah um sorry casper mason
sorry can you repeat that please
counselling
right can you i didn't catch quite what
you were saying that i about potholes
yes on an unadopted highway
the people that live in unadopted
highway areas still pay their rates and
taxes the same as everybody else yeah
and the reason that they are unadopted
is that the development has not been
paid for to the standards required by
well out of the development took place
hundred years ago
it's a bit different
i think that's a discussion for outside
this meeting
i can assure you
county highways will not look at taking
on unadopted highways until they are
made up to a standard which meets their
drivers this is a separate
issue and it
and it's not what we're discussing now
so do someone indicate that i missed yes
mason
chairman have you looked at project
teams on the back yet yes i was just
going to go to those
because they're on the very very back
well that's right i wasn't sure whether
the page or not so we have um
well the ict contract is coming back as
i said which includes the ipad issue and
third party software
um russia district masters reported
building control
has not yet reported which i have a
problem with
um
we are
i might suggest that building control
seemed good to me i'm not sure what the
thoughts around here are on that i'm not
sure we're going to achieve anything
much it is now in a position where we
in my opinion we could now
look at building control with a view to
putting forward a recommendation
to how it should proceed
but obviously that would not be done
within this
council period it wouldn't
be able to report it after may
the elections any thoughts
that did is there anybody left in
building control
yeah
yes was the answer is that
yeah okay yeah um
but the manager obviously has got
always going yeah under the
reorganization that's what i mean so how
can we know if there's nobody there so
i presume that something's going to
happen within the reorganization yeah
and that could be something that this
the building truck or this kind of
people back to sorry castle mason
thank you
i've been
rather disappointed that
i almost would say a level of
cooperation
um
with this particular project team has
not been forthcoming notwithstanding i
know
the
interventions you've made and the
interventions in particular have been
made with our chief executive and i've
been hugely disappointed that um
a more positive response to the project
team's questions hasn't happened and
more particularly the chief executive is
more or less declined to come before the
review committee and update us even in
exempt
so
i
i feel we should keep this on review
committee
and not in any way diminish it even
though it may be carried forward
to ensure that review committee does
receive
an appropriate um response
from the chief executive or the office
of machinery generally
on on the question
um i think it should come back to review
committee even if it's not in this this
cycle
thank you very much